so leute da sind wir wieder was soll ich sagen massive pepo fett wisst ihr was ich gegessen
habe ich sollte jetzt mal warten bis switch am start ist
ich habe leider keine fotos gemacht habe ich erst nachher dran gedacht ich habe ja ganz
normalen wir haben ja burger bestellt normalerweise ist ja raclette stelz am an silvester angesagt
aber irgendwie hat er dieses jahr keiner bock drauf gehabt ich habe burger bestellt so ich
habe ich habe jetzt gefuttert also nicht komplette drei burger aber drei drei verschiedene teile
von weil crunchy crunchy chicken burger chili cheese burger und mexikan style burger da
kann man sich jetzt nicht so viel drunter vorstellen also unter unser chili cheese kann
man sich glaube ich noch am ehesten was vorstellen das ist so ein standard ding was es so fast
überall gibt so was hier in der richtung aber nicht burger king alter glaubt man ich
habe nicht burger king bestellt aber sowas in der richtung war das double crunchy oder
wie das andere nicht crunchy crunchy burger das waren quasi so zwei hähnchen crunchy chicken
war es genau waren so zwei hähnchen dinger bis zur unkenntlichkeit frittiert übereinander
auch geil geschmeckt und dann noch mexikan style burger das war im prinzip zwiebel onion
ringe und es ist komische mischung also also onion und onion ringe frittiert natürlich
alles frittiert was sonst und auch hähnchen excellent und dabei riesenportion krautsalat
kennt ihr diesen kfc style krautsalat richtig kokona style kennt ihr diesen kfc krautsalat
ihr seht das da schmeckt übelst nice aber ich hab nicht kfc bestellt aber die haben
auch sowas also poggers richtig kokona style massive high calorie gamer
wir brauchen wir müssen wir brauchen übrigens das pepo fett gibt's pepo fett gibt sogar
ein gif von das ist viel besser pepo fett gif
pepo fett wir brauchen das gif oder die coolen leute sagen gif aber gif ist falsch hier
alter das will ich alles gar nicht sehen hier das da brauchen wir das ist poggers guck mal
pepo fett gif das muss
excellent so ist das nice oder kein kobold streben ich bin ultra voll gefressen leute
ich penne also chat wenn uns nicht irgendwas einfällt ich penne ein ohne scheiß ich schlaf
einfach instant ein so voll bin ich gefressen resident sleeper ich wache dann irgendwann
nachts um 2 auf weil tropf's klo muss oder so wahrscheinlich ich war gerade eben auch
auf dem klo soll ich euch was sagen ist das bein eingeschlafen excellent das wollte jetzt
alle wissen ich weiß ja und nochmal soll ich euch mal was wirklich poggers zeigen was
was richtig poggers ist chat ihr kennt euch da besser aus als ich früher hat man immer
social plate verwendet für youtube und twitch stats aber da gibt's doch jetzt so eine neue
seit ich hab vergessen wie die heißt weiß das jemand von euch ist das bessere social
plate klop kommt sogar aus deutschland nindu was nindu ja ich glaube das meine ich sogar
ja ich glaube ich glaube das meine ich sogar so also ich zeige euch was das richtig poggers
ist als erstes gucken wir uns mal twitch an twitch
warte mal ich muss mal kurz gucken was wie sieht es auf twitch aus den letzten 30 tagen
was ist das wie viewer und ihn kenne ich nicht aber das hier so quasi das das rtl von twitch
auf 1 und 2 trimex kenne ich nur von einem warzone turnier krank gut stable seit jahren
pizmita auch pappa platte sagt mir vom namen her was aber keine ahnung gut aber was ich
euch zeigen wollte viel viel poggers viel mehr poggers was interessieren leute mit 38.000
views ja
warum weiß der dass ich warum weiß die seite das was soll das die seite kann mich doch
nicht einfach so liegen also das erste guckt euch das mal an exquisite also es hat sich
gelohnt erstens werbung auf youtube zu machen bis in youtube zu machen und und regelmäßig
zu zu zu zu streamen erst mal exquisite growth hier stonks richtig stonks geht nach oben
ich hatte streams freigegeben für erwachsenen ehrlich nicht
eben extrem ist bestimmt wahnsinnig wäre bestimmt wahnsinnig beliebt auf twitch gibt
auch leute die stream einfach die verfügbarkeit von grafikern man sieht mal typische streamtage
außer sonntag habe ich keinen festen tag einfach random typische streamzeiten sind auch nicht
so wirklich konsistent muss man sagen was ich bin twitch 301 ich bin 361 wie sollen
das funktionieren wenn ich schon 361 spinn was sind der andere dann ich meine ich habe
doch nicht ich habe doch nicht viel auf twitch es werden bewertet
ich habe keine ahnung was es sein soll zumindest worauf ich eigentlich raus will was ich eigentlich
raus will wisst ihr was richtig poggers ist ich zeige es euch mal guckt mal ich habe seit
glaube ich und ohne scheiß seit sechs jahren habe ich 2000 keine ahnung 75k und kaw machst
immer wieder was also den letzten sprung hatte ich vor zwei jahren wo ich ein bisschen was
gemacht habe aber ich habe seit sechs jahren glaube also ich glaube ich habe jetzt wieder
mehr abos als vor 6000 jahre vor 6000 als vor sechs jahren ich habe danach nichts mehr
gemacht stonks ja ich die stonks guck mal gut von null ja ich bin sogar live sagt guck
mal da stimmt nicht fake news sind nur 142 wo kann man deine aktien kaufen beim friseur
im haarsalon der aber gerade geschlossen hat infinite cross infinite detail kennt ihr
noch dieses video mit dieser komischen grafik engine infinite detail aber das ist nice also
das freut mich da sieht man mal dass es wieder lohnt und was auch cool ist kann man richtig
schreiben was auch cool ist dass die letzten videos auch wirklich wieder all guckt euch
das mal an hier also für das für jemand der quasi seit sechs jahren nichts mehr macht
was irgendjemand interessiert geschweige denn überhaupt was macht ich habe ich max fdp
eingegeben ich habe ich habe schon gesagt vielleicht wähle ich sogar die fdp nächste
wahl ich sonst nicht weiß wen ich wählen soll oder ich mache das was ich immer mache
aber was was echt nice ist die dass dass dass die leute das guck mal bald bald hat es 69
k und was bei dem video witzig ist ein paar leute fühlen sich übelst angepisst wenn
wir hier mal die kommentare durchgehen wenn man die kommentare man das IT stellenangebote
wurden mir empfohlen exquisite so muss das sein dann funktioniert der algorithmus wenigstens
manche waren übelst angepisst hier in dem video in den kommentaren und haben gesagt
dass das stimmt alles nicht oder natürlich muss der mitarbeiter sich voll mit der firma
identifizieren das ist immer so weißt ihr wisst ihr wenn ich so kommentare lese dann
denke ich mir immer so ist das nicht ein bisschen einseitig ist das nicht ein bisschen einseitig
ich meine warum sollte ich mich so auch warum sollte ich mich quasi so blind mit der firma
der firma trauen und die firma kann jederzeit auf mich scheißen warum soll ich sowas denn
machen das sind hannah die da schreiben also meine manche meinen das ernst und das kann
ich auch schon akzeptieren wenn man das anders sieht ja aber manche kommen manche kommen
sind wirklich pepega gewesen hier drin was haben wir hier ja ok er hat einen halben roman
geschrieben kann ich aber nachvollziehen was er schreibt das halben roman das finde ich
halt auch geil das ist sowas in der richtung viele leute geschrieben aber wie gesagt ich
will die dort nicht flamen oder so also ich kann das kann es auch ein andere meinung
zu hat als ich ja hier also unseren mittler ich finde den einserleitungssatz so geil also
unseren mitarbeitern ist es richtig wichtig sich mit dem arbeitgeber und aufgaben zu
identifizieren also ich habe so das gefühl die mitarbeiter sagen ihm nicht die wahrheit
weil er der chef ist wenn er der chef ist ja und du fragst du fragst deine mitarbeiter
identifizieren sie sich mit ihrem arbeitgeber ja na klar ich komm ohne scheiß wenn der
chef zu dir kommt ja desillusionen und wenn der chef zu einem kommt ja und frag dich quasi
und findest du wir sind ein geiles unternehmen kaum einer lehnt sich da so weit aus dem
fenster und sagt nee chef wir sacken übelst ich bin nur hier um geld zu verdienen keiner
wer soll dann sowas sagen die sagen selbstverständlich alle das natürlich was denn sonst vor allem
das ist auch kein es geht wie gesagt kein hate oder so wie gesagt andere ansichten sind
durchaus ok und ich habe in den video auch ein bisschen übertrieben an manchen stellen
muss bei der schon verfahren verfahren ist halber sagen ja aber das ist auch kein es
geht bei der it meiner meinung nach null darum einfach nur geld zu machen also um ehrlich
zu sein also ok nur nur würde ich sagen ja also es geht es geht generell nicht drum
nur geld zu machen aber um ehrlich zu sein doch schon zum größten teil und wenn man
ehrlich ist also wenn man ehrlich ist geht es beiden seiten darum ich gehe dahin weil
ich sonst verhungere ok jetzt übertrieben gesagt ich meine es macht nicht jeder noch
twitch youtube und ein bisschen anderes geschiss aber die meisten leute gehen auf die arbeit
dass sie nicht verhungern müssen und vielleicht manche um pepo fett zu werden und die arbeitskraft
der leute wird zu geld gemacht natürlich was denn sonst na gut aber ich will mich nicht
zu sehr darüber auflassen ja und am geilsten finde ich die es gibt ja in den kommentaren
welche die reden die reden diese bahnanzeige ist schön guck mal diese bahnanzeige die ich
hier am ende drin hatte ich habe übrigens einen fehler gemacht leute in dem video ich
habe mich haben richtigen fehler gemacht in dem video das werde ich das ist jetzt nicht
so schlimm aber das werde ich im nächsten video anders machen ich habe stellenanzeigen
aus frankfurt genommen und das dumme daran ist wenn ich jetzt noch keine ahnung ich stelle
euch mal vor ich mache jetzt 50 solcher videos und flame alle arbeitgeber in frankfurt rauf
und runter und ich gehe mal irgendwo anders hin und bewerb mich und die kommen irgendwie
dahinter dass ich das bin dann nehmen die mich ja nicht jetzt ist das nicht so wild ja aber
das nächste mal das nächste mal nehme ich nehme ich andere die die nicht aus frankfurt
kommen ja genau und es gab ganz viel in den kommentaren also wie gesagt wenn ich mal lachen
wollte müssen die kommentare ein bisschen durchlesen bald machst du eh nur noch stream
und youtube ach nee das glaube ich nicht ich will ich will ich will wirklich unbedingt
beides machen mach doch mal aus der schweiz das stimmt aber da kann ich da wobei der
prinzip ist der gleiche stuss wahrscheinlich ja was wollte ich jetzt sagen im prinzip will
ich ja beides machen ich will ja ich will ja stream youtube und normal arbeiten gehen
weil ich habe es gesehen jetzt mal jetzt mal ernsthaft leute also keck serious ja es ist
sehr entspannend wenn du weißt dass du das eine nicht brauchst weil du das andere hast
und das andere nicht brauchst weil du das eine hast wisst ihr was ich meine also ich
kann jetzt beispielsweise sagen ich habe keinen bock auf youtube und twitch geht mir alles
auf den sack habe ich so genug geld ich kann auch sagen die arbeit geht mir auf den sack
dann habe ich mit twitch und youtube genug geld also das ist sehr sehr das ist wirklich
entspannend prime subscription massive saber fz iq plus gleich plus eins ne plus gleich
eins was laber ich denn die frage was mir das kann man ganz einfach beantworten beantworten
die arbeit wirft mir ab aktuell ich habe ja quasi außer diesen monat jetzt auf iq plus
plus genau ich habe ja außer diesen monat ist ja quasi fast nichts gemacht auf youtube
und twitch twitch also ich kann ich kann euch das sagen twitch gibt ich sage euch mal wie
viel subs ich habe jet ratet mal was meint ihr bei wie viel subs bei mir gerade sind
wir gerade 69 100 400 300 150 60 420 zu wenig ja das ist auf jeden fall ne also aktuell
sind wir bei 232 was insofern nice ist weil ich kriege davon 2,5 euro pro subscriber
also kann man ja mal ausrecht natürlich muss ich noch steuern drauf bezahlen dafür nicht
vergessen ich muss ja spitzenscheuersatz bezahlen also wisst ihr leute ich bin ja so reich mit
meinen vier tage arbeiten und ein bisschen youtube twitch ich bin ja so reich dass ich
unbedingt spitzenssteuersatz bezahlen muss das ist das ist echt so pepega in deutsch
da könnte ich mich jetzt mal drüber aufregen also ich kriege ungefähr von von twitch dann
zeigt mal her ja also 580 euro davon bezahlt die hälfte steuern wobei das nicht ganz stimmt
ich bezahle nicht die hälfte steuern das ist nicht richtig weil es sind ja glaube
ich maximal 46 oder 48 oder so und dadurch dass ich immer so viel technik kaufe was
ich absetzen kann für mein für die firma habe ich habe ich ein bisschen schmiede rung
das gewinnt ja was ist für musik so richtig an nele style an paper mache stickers da hat
er sein twitch income geliegt ja da sehe ich kein geheimnis weil ich also bei einer sache
chat bei einer sache bin ich massiv pingelig ich gebe jeden scheiß an steuer erklärungsmäßig
wobei die sache die ist das ist nicht wirklich alles es gibt ja noch ein bisschen geld durch
werbung und ich hoffe ja vielleicht klappt das nächstes jahr dass ich irgendeinen also
ich nenne es mal nicht sponsor weil ein sponsor in dem sinn ist es ja nicht irgendwie so sponsoring
partnership geschichte finde was ich für beide seiten was ich für beide seiten irgendwie
lohnt das muss halt auch was sein was zu meinem stream passt auf youtube ist das kein problem
gaming gaming geschätzt hast du wirklich wie sand am meer kein problem können wir drüber
reden mache ich sellout modus ist real kein problem spiegelfirma vpn ist halt ich kann
nicht auf der einen seite so einen schwachsinn machen wie videos wie kacke vpn anbieter sind
an vpn machen das funktioniert nicht aber vielleicht die eine andere sache muss ich
mal gucken da gibt es bestimmt gibt es bestimmt ein paar dinger die man die man drehen kann
ja beispielsweise bei den englischen sprachen englischsprachen technik channels sind so
diese selbst die seiten pcb seiten recht im trend habe ich eigentlich immer noch chili
cheeseburger auf gut wie sind wir da jetzt zu hingekommen genau ich wollte ich wollte
nämlich noch was sagen also was ich auch besonders lustig fand hier in den kommentaren von dem von
diesem stellenanzeigen video ich mein leute ja ihr habt ihr habt wahrscheinlich teilweise
gesehen das video oder ich denke mal die meistens wenn sie gesehen haben also was meint ihr also
wie kommt das wie kommt das an bei euch also hört sich das für euch an als will ich die auf teufel
kommen raus schlecht machen oder hört sich das eher so an als finde ich halt übertrieben
und macht das halt auch weil es irgendwo lustig ist ja also in den kommentaren haben ganz viele
so getan als mache ich das nur um die als schlecht zu freimen so nach dem motto ich bin
der meinung das ist wirklich kacke zum größten teil und ich halt mache mich halt ein bisschen
auch entertainment zwecken drüber lustig ja paul b197 dankeschön für den sub massive
subscription iq plus plus so und zumindest was ich dazu sagen wollte es haben sich an
dieser bahnanzeige haben sich auch richtig viele gestört weil passt mal auf jetzt kommt jetzt
kommt die erklärung jeder also das muss ich anders anfangen ihr kennt ihr diese kommentare
die ohne es zu sagen einem instant die kompetenz absprechen oder oder generell so dieser dieser
dieser rhetorik trick den manche leute versuchen so einem quasi ohne es zu sagen die kompetenz
abzusprechen so nach dem motto ich sag nicht alle du sparst was du laberst ist kacke sondern
ich sag also wenn man sich mit dem thema beschäftigt hat dann weiß man doch dass das so und so ist
so nach dem motto so so so komplett anders als mit dem video gesagt hat und da gibt es auch
ein paar comments in dieser richtung die haben dann quasi gesagt ja also jeder der sich mit
stellenanzeigen und der jeder der sich in diesem sektor auskennt der wird ja sofort erkennen dass
die bahn in wirklichkeit dass das ein oder ist die suchen quasi einen full stack engineer oder
einen frontend engineer wobei man immer noch sagen muss hier ist kein oder dazwischen ja aber mal
davon abgesehen was macht es denn für einen sinn denn oder in die stellenanzeige zu machen wenn
sich die stellenanzeige auf komplett unterschiedliche sachen bescheid bezieht ja das ist so wie wie wenn
ich ebay klein anzeigen was schalten würde und sagen und sagen würde also ich suche einen
kühlschrank oder einen herd oder einen staubsauger was hat das eine mit dem anderen zu tun wenn ich
sagen würde ich suche einen herd oder eine mikrowelle ok kann ich ja verstehen aber der
rest der gibt überhaupt keinen sinn der fobs oder oder koch genau oder ist ja aber das haben wie
gesagt die die pros in den kommens haben das gesagt und was ich mir halt immer bei diesen
stellenanzeigen denke wenn es halt gar so gar gar so wir ist wenn die schon selbst nicht schreiben
können was die eigentlich haben wollen dann frage ich mich halt immer wie es läuft wie läuft es in
dem laden an sich schon ab ich weiß das läuft ähnlich wie bei uns ab da blickt auch keiner
durch aber hat sich teilweise witzige witzige kommens ach ja und da haben sie ich muss sagen
den also die habe ich ein bisschen hart ran genommen die ersten ja was gab es vorhin zu
essen exquisite drei verschiedene burger die ersten habe ich ein bisschen hart ran genommen
ja aber die waren halt auch die waren halt auch der einstieg ich habe aber keine drei burger
gefuttert moin michael 50 billion kannst du kochen geht geht halbwegs aber nicht hier massive chef
koch und da haben sich viele darüber beschwert dass die ja einen senior entwickler suchen und
deswegen ist vollkommen normal ist dass der total viel verantwortung übernimmt unter anderem auch
sich um team koordination kümmert und da muss ich halt sagen ok es mag vielleicht normal sein in
den leden wo die wo die sind vielleicht ist es sogar vielleicht ist das sogar normal in diesem
sinn aber die frage ist ja viel eher sollte der das ist das eine faire sache und das finde ich
ist es nicht du kannst nicht jemand suchen für für technik und dem dann noch 50.000 andere
aufgaben auf auf aufs auge drücken so nach dem motto aber du bist ja senior und vor allem
wo soll denn bitteschön der fokus drauf liegen du kannst team leitung nicht nebenbei machen
wie willst du team leitung nebenbei machen wie soll das funktionieren du kannst du kannst doch
schlecht alles das machen und noch team leitung wie klappt das schon richtig patrick genauso
sehe ich das auch senior heißt dass du erfahrung da drinne hast und es auch dementsprechend gut
kannst so und das heißt nicht dass ich automatisch jeden anderen scheiß auch noch mitmach also im
human resources mindset mag das wahrscheinlich so heißen ja aber es ergibt keinen sinn
naja egal da ist genug genug drüber drüber hergezogen
warum habe ich denn an alpha 4 games mal was geschrieben
ok alles klar ich habe keine ahnung was es ging
human resource das ist die geilste umschreibung sehr gute erkenntnisse für java das wäre ja
was für dich ja eindeutig bin aber kantlicher maß nach so die java checker
wisst ihr wisst ihr was echt schlimm ist wenn man es mal genau sich überlegt ich kann besser
cobalt als java also ich habe mehr erfahrung mit cobalt als mit java
cobalt master race mario ist crying warum ist er crying weil er kassen kirby dance moves sieht
ja alles klar leute ich bin so voll gefressen es gibt es nicht javascript ist ok klar javascript
ist poggers wir brauchen ein ordentliches feuerwerk gif brauchen ordentliches feuerwerk
gif was ich hier im hintergrund starten kann gibt es gibt es ein ordentliches feuerwerk feuerwerk
javascript mäßig example example hier exzellent alle sieht das hässlich aus
was darf das sieht aus wie slither.io und nicht wie feuerwerk alle hattest du nicht
letztes jahr was gab doch ich glaube schon ich habe es mir aber nicht gespeichert ok
das sagt das brauchen wir nicht js fireworks die haben doch da bestimmt noch irgendwas hier
das haben wir letztes jahr leute ich glaube das hatten wir letztes jahr aber man konnte konnte
man das nicht hatte das nicht sound noch letztes jahr irgendwann das hatte es nicht noch sound
gab letztes jahr aus sechs jahre altes fireworks js exzellent wird ja immer als ein schlimmer
als das andere som fireworks fireworks exzellent monkaS wtf jetzt muss klatschen leute
das hatten wir letztes jahr echt ach war das das wo man reinklicken konnte ah genau
was leckt massive leck
wieviel cpu las braucht man braucht man browser
konnte man dem task manager nicht sagen dass der dass der always on top
ok cpu ist nicht so das ding gpu gpu
warum leckt das so
single core single single credit ist das ja nur
das ist ein cpu core ein cpu core ist wahrscheinlich dicht ok exzellente speicher ich mir mal das
brauchen wir dann wenn es soweit ist
usage very high was sonst
gleich ist der browser weg aber man muss sagen das ist mittlerweile ziemlich resistent
also gerade chrome chrome hat ja auch so ein task manager drin wo ich jetzt grad nicht
weiß wo er ist aber chrome hat so ein task manager
das ist mittlerweile ziemlich stabil also ich muss sagen mir ist firefox öfters abgekackt
als chrome ich weiß nicht wie es bei euch aussieht aber firefox kackt öfters mal ab
da steht dann ups das hätte nicht passieren dürfen steht dann da bei firefox
ups genau also bei mir kackt firefox mehr ab als chrome
nutzt du ungoogle chromium ähm ich glaube das ist die variante mit codex ich bin mir
aber nicht ganz sicher
oben rechts unter weitere tools ach hier genau den task manager meine ich genau exquisite
um null uhr müssten wir live stream aus anderem land aufmachen nee nee nee nee um null uhr
um null uhr machen wir dann das da
alles gut
ähm ich könnte euch ja um null uhr meine ld fensterbeleuchtung einblenden weil heute
machen wir folgendes twitter heute machen wir folgendes
heute machen wir das mit der led beleuchtung
guck mal das mache ich heute an led beleuchtung
wenn es schon kein feuerwerk gibt dann mache ich meine led beleuchtung an
das ist nicht nice
exquisite oder
das da unten liegt übrigens nicht mehr da das ist mittlerweile schöner gemacht
ich dachte jetzt war es jetzt cobalt oder ab ab
pax wo nord liegt ich glaube ich bin nicht der einzige der diese led fensterbeleuchtung
hat
ich will kein abab und kein kobold machen das ist beides kacke
als nächstes kommt was fortran oder was
alter der chat ist ja richtig scharf drauf
nein nein nein das war das war auch nicht ernst gemeint ich werde es sap garantiert
nicht anfassen
kann man hat irgendjemand ich muss da wirklich ich will es nicht flamen muss ich gleich dazu
sagen ich will es nicht flamen ich habe davon keine ahnung hat jemand eine ahnung warum
sap benutzt wird also was was machen die was sonst keiner macht
no homo no hate genau
stonks
irgendwas müssen die ja machen lobbyarbeit irgendwas muss ja sein
historisch gewachsen
hat der hat er ihr wisst ich habe von fußball keine ahnung hat der sap typ nicht in fußball
team gekauft von paar jahren
so der balmer hat sich ja auch ein basketball team gekauft
sap ist schrecklich aber es funktioniert ja gut da gibt es noch mehr was schrecklich
ist aber es funktioniert
wisst ihr wisst ihr was auch schrecklich ist und funktioniert
das ist ein mailprogramm also ein mail ne das stimmt nicht es ist eigentlich kein mail
programm
es ist so eine so ne pimm pimm lösung die aber anders funktioniert als jede andere pimm
lösung
ist
ich bin so voll gefressen ich hänge voll in den seilen das kann überhaupt nicht ich
gebe ich gebe mir übelst mühe hier ja da ich schon ein bisschen energie wieder krieg
ich versuche schon übelst motiviert zu klingen dass ich dass ich ein bisschen mich vom fressen
erhole
kann dir 10 kilo fett abgeben na da habe ich selbst genug
ich könnte auch mal easy 20 kilo los werden das wäre alles noch in ordnung
cobalt ja cobalt gibt bestimmt wahnsinnig viel energie
t plus plus oder ab ab ehrlich ganz ehrlich dann sogar t plus plus aber t plus plus
ist halt dermaßen scheiße das sagt schon alles oder
neujahrsvorsätze ja da kann ich was zu sagen
keine weil ich finde dass neujahrsvorsätze überhaupt nichts bringen wenn man wirklich
was machen will macht man es gleich das ist das beste was man machen kann weil
überlegt jetzt muss ich mal philosophie mag max filo filo so fair philosophierung
stellts machen überlegt euch mal ihr wollt wirklich
unbedingt irgendwas machen wo ist der sinn zu warten bis neujahr
ist es ist doch viel besser man fängt wirklich gleich an weil es gibt jetzt mal immer hand
aufs herz bei ehrlich die meisten dinge die man angefangen hat und wenn man die eine
weile macht dann denkt man sich warum habe ich nicht
schon ein halbes jahr vorher angefangen oder warum habe ich das nicht schon vor zwei jahren
angefangen
das ist bei ganz vielen sachen so ganz viel wenn man sich erst mal dazu durchgerungen
hat die zu machen sagt man man warum habe ich das nicht schon von warum habe ich das
nicht schon früher gemacht deswegen einfach einfach anfangen
was ist mit der musik los
das hört sich immer so abgedreht an ist echt so also ich finde neujahrsvorsätze bringen
nichts
spät gesagt ich habe dieses jahr fünf kilo abgenommen aber die hälfte davon wahrscheinlich
auch nur muskelmasse excellent ich habe ich habe dieses jahr auch
ein bisschen was abgenommen und ihr wisst auch warum das habe ich nämlich schon erzählt
ihr wisst ja ich hatte dieses jahr zum ersten mal in meinem leben eine meldepflichtige krankheit
aber es war nicht korona ich habe mir irgendeine komische irgendwelche komischen bakterien
geholt beim lieferservice und ich hatte über eine woche dünnschiss und da habe ich abgenommen
muss vom lieferservice sein ohne scheiß ich habe zwei ich habe zwei lieferservice zur
auswahl einmal habe ich döner teller bestellt und einmal habe ich rahmschnitzel bestellt
beim italiener so und das war das rahmschnitzel ich bin mir ziemlich sicher was anderes kann
es nicht gewesen sein also döner teller döner teller ich habe zweimal ich habe ich habe
zweimal türkisch bestellt das eine war zu früh und das andere war quasi am tag davor
bevor es losging das ist zu nah dran was hatteste ich habe vergessen wie das irgendwie bakter
bakter irgendwas ich habe vergessen wie es hieß irgendwas bakter bakterien zeug
pilo bakter das klingt gut ja oder gut das klingt klingt richtig ja niemals bei italiener
ein fleisch bestellen warum nicht ich ich hole mir total oft rahmschnitzel bei italiener
schmeckt richtig gut aber das ist wobei das stimmt übrigens leute wenn man streng genau
nimmt stimmt das gar nicht das ist zwar eine lieferservice der so so 085 generik italienische
namen hat aber die owner sind keine italiener die owner sind irgendein gem noch irgendwas
das sind jetzt also entweder entweder sind es türkische owner oder indische owner ich
weiß dann mal genau also es sind eigentlich gar keine italiener was aber im prinzip egal
ist weil es wird kein lieferdienst absichtlich schlechtes essen machen das ist einfach ökonomisch
betrachtet bescheuert ja die haben einfach nicht richtig aufgepasst was aber auch sagt
jud gorino dankeschön stufe 1 subscription massive übrigens jetzt mal unpopuläre meinung
da werdet ihr mir nicht zustimmen gehe ich mal von aus aber ich sag jetzt mal trotzdem
ich bin der meinung döner pide äh nicht döner pide äh pide mit sucuk schmeckt besser
als salami pizza
beides monarch ist ne warum der chat gibt mir recht excellent ich mag das wenn man mir
recht gibt sehr schön chat was können wir irgendwas sinnvolles machen außer dass ich
jetzt hier sitze und warte bis 24 Uhr ist und irgendwelches zeug vor mich hin laber
ich könnte reacten auf irgendein altes video bleck meser habe ich keinen bock drauf ich
komme ich reakt auf irgendwas altes aber nicht von mir reagte auf das cringe video mit fabian
mit dem l2 oh nein das sika alter nein da kann ich drauf reaktion das geht nicht das
sika oh nein das sika video die leute die leute sind geil gewesen in dem video die leute
waren richtig geil in dem video max du spiegels dich ihr müsst mal die kommentare durchgucken
die haben steif und fest behauptet das sind keine nanolies sind einfach spiegel sieht
aus wie nanolies die haben steif und fest behauptet max bei minute keine ahnung bei
minute 1101 sieht man dich im spiegel guck mal von wann das ist und wisst ihr was das
geile ist der fabian sieht aus wie 16 oder so in dem dreh ja und wisst ihr wie alt wir
damals waren wir waren damals irgendwie 27 oder so 26 27 er sieht aus wie 16 aber ich
sah damals auch noch relativ jung aus mittlerweile mittlerweile sehe ich auch boomer mäßig aus
und das liegt zum größten teil daran weil ich mit weniger haare habe und graue graue
teilweise auch alter wo haben was hier wo ist wo ist wo baut ob ich kabe ich kann kein
wo baut wo ist wo ist mein alt der 3ds ist alt ja das sika unboxing das ist das ist
Das Black Ops SC-Cover war auch so richtig billiger Shit, ne?
Cut-SFPS, welche? Du meinst, du meinst die hier?
Die Originale, die gibt's schon jahrelang nicht mehr.
Cut-SFPS.
Die war ja da auch schon 14 oder 15 oder so.
Origin.
Ey, das ist Splatoon-Musik. Splatoon-Musik ist immer abfuck.
Ey, ich versteh's nicht, ne? Splatoon ist auch so ein Game.
Übelst verkackter Multiplayer.
Aber wisst ihr, warum Splatoon so viele Fans hat?
Also der einzige Grund, der einzige Grund, ähm, was ich mir erklären kann,
warum Splatoon so viele Fans hat.
Also das einzige, was irgendwie Sinn ergibt.
Ne, das einzige, was irgendwie Sinn ergibt, ist, dass die Leute, ähm,
merkwürdige Vorlieben haben, ja?
Drücken wir's mal so aus.
Was meint ihr, warum Overwatch so lang so beliebt war?
Warum war Overwatch bei so vielen Leuten beliebt?
Bei so vielen Leuten, die eigentlich mit dieser Sorte Game überhaupt nichts anfangen können.
Aber mit Sicherheit war, hat es Salami-Gründe gehabt.
Kannste drauf, kannst du, kannst du halt drauf lassen, äh,
kannst du, kannst du halt drauf lassen, äh.
Übrigens, wo wir gerade beim Thema sind, ich darf's jetzt nicht zu sehr übertreiben,
weil sonst ist es Monka Toss, ja?
Ähm.
Haben wir Monka Toss nur mal, nur mal aus rein,
rein wissenschaftlichen Gründen gefragt an den Chat,
weil ich weiß, dass, gerade der Sebaro, falls der da ist, der kennt sich mit so was ja gut aus.
Hat jemand das Belle-Delfin-Video gesehen?
Mehrfach, mehrfach?
Alter, so schlecht, ey.
Also wer da für Geld bezahlt, da tut mir echt leid, ja?
Also wer da für, wer, wer da für hunderte Euro Onlyfans oder sonst was bezahlt, da tut mir echt leid.
Das ist so dermaßen schlecht, alter, so unglaublich kacke.
Schlimmer als der Scam-Trail, ja? Schon.
Also es ist, es ist so dermaßen schlecht.
Also, es ist, es ist so dermaßen schlecht.
Es ist auch so schlecht gemacht und, alter.
Ich fand das richtig eklig, ehrlich gesagt.
Also, nee.
Nee, nee, ich weiß nicht, also.
Da hat die Welt echt nicht drauf gewartet.
Da hat die Welt nun wirklich nicht drauf gewartet, ja.
Ja, Patrick sehe ich auch so, ey, echt.
Das ist wirklich eines der schlechtesten Sachen aller Zeiten, ey.
Da ist ja Alarm Alarm noch besser.
Kennt ihr das eigentlich? Das ist schon, schaut mal so, das kennt wahrscheinlich gar keiner mehr.
Kennt Alarm Alarm noch jemand?
Also ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich kenne den Film nicht.
Ich kenne nur diese, ich kenne nur diese eine Szene da draus.
Es ist so dermaßen schlecht, alter.
Hey, was suchst du denn hier?
Ich wollte nur mal so eine Uniform anprobieren.
Die wolltest du wohl klauen?
Komm, komm.
Alarm.
Das ist so dermaßen schlecht.
Also ich würde sagen, es ist
nach, warum liegt hier Stroh
die bekannteste
die bekannteste deutsche Porn-Szene
überhaupt, ja.
Ich glaube, die kennt jeder.
Ich kenne den Film, ich weiß nicht,
ich wüsste nicht mehr den Titel davon, ja.
Ich habe auch ehrlich gesagt
keinen Hang dazu,
ausgereicht diesen Film hier anzugucken
nach diesem Clip.
Das haben die doch damals nicht
ernst gemeint, das ist halt Porn-Acting.
Also sprich
einfach nur irgendwas machen,
dass es auch abgeht.
Der scheiß Gnome.
Ruby.
Die Pornosynchro kennst du auch, ne.
Aber jetzt mal wieder zu anderen Themen,
Leute.
Ja, wir sind ein bisschen
abgedriftet, ja.
Moin, hier ist Anna3.
Ja, wir sind ein bisschen abgedriftet,
ja.
Moin, hier ist Anna3.
Wir sind ein bisschen abgedriftet.
Wie viele Subs
müsste man giften, dass man darauf reagiert?
Hä?
Was ist das denn?
Moment, Moment.
Ich habe mal in einem Stream
auf mein Gartenstells
Video reagiert.
Und jetzt soll ich auf
die Reaktion der Reaktion reagieren.
Ne, das ist mir doch ein bisschen viel des Guten.
Schaut euch das mal an.
Okay, damals
hatte das Video 2.074.000.
Was hat denn das heute?
Na, immerhin 4000
Views mehr.
Reakte doch mal auf.
Was ein Hacker
erpresst mich, kein Fake. Oh, ne.
Das ist bestimmt so richtig dumm.
Sollte ich mir nicht angucken.
Das ist bestimmt richtig dumm, sowas gucke ich mir nicht an.
Wisst ihr, Leute? Jeder kennt...
Na ja, sogar auf...
E-Ball, ja. E-Ball und Amazon
hat er auch resettet. E-Ball
kündigt hier eine nicht...
Ja, wie wäre es mit 2-Faktor-Authentifizierung,
ne?
Ja, ich weiß, der macht
teilweise schon ganz brauchbare Sachen.
Ist das nicht so einer, der immer irgendwelche
wie wir es hier,
Selbstexperiment oder was auch immer
macht?
Hä, das ist Pain's Jam,
das gucken wir uns nicht an.
Man muss ja immer sagen,
das meiste Zeug
hat ja mit gehackt werden
relativ wenig zu tun.
Zu 99% dürfte das
sein, weil die Leute irgendwelche easy zu erraten
Passwörter verwendet haben
oder aber...
Das ist das, was ich denke, was
auch bei vielen, bei ihm eher
nicht. Ich glaube, der ist kein Techniknoob.
Was bei auch bei vielen Leuten passiert,
die haben sich in den Keylogger eingefangen.
So, die 2 Sachen dürfte so mit das
größte sein, ja.
Oder halt der Klassiker
irgendeine Mail gekriegt
mit, äh, hallo hier,
Amazon Support oder so.
Ja, Michael, da gibt's nur eine Sache.
Du musst das einfach
anders vor einer Weiche runterladen.
Nicht über den Rechner, den du normalerweise benutzt.
Zum Beispiel aus der Linux VM.
Das ist, dann ist easy.
Ich, Leute, ich verstehe
immer noch nicht wirklich, ich kann
es nicht verstehen, warum dieses Video
2 Millionen Aufrufe hat.
Ich muss mal gucken,
was ist das Video von Montana Black
mit den meisten Aufrufen.
Alter, die Musik geht mir ein bisschen auf den Sack.
Das ist Yoshi Musik.
Ja.
Was ist das Video
mit den meisten, oh, der hat mehr.
Most Popular.
Ah, fuck.
Okay, okay.
Montana Blacks bekannteste Video hat doppelt
so viel wie der Gartenstelz.
Du wünschst dir nicht mehr als Gartenstelz
2.0.
Da müssen wir mal schauen, wie wird denn das Wetter.
Äh, was gibt's denn für eine gute Wetterseite
hier, Wetter, Wetter, Wetter online oder keine Ahnung.
So, gucken wir mal,
Hanau, Hanau, ob's da schneit, schauen wir mal.
Watte.
Hallo, Hanau?
Also, wann schneit's
in Hanau?
Aussicht
für, haben die auch irgendwie eine
10-Tage-Vorschau oder sowas?
Wohnort liegt, oh, schauen wir mal.
Wupp, Wupp liegt.
Ähm,
hier, 16 Tage.
Ja,
ja, kommt mir doch bekannt vor.
Bestes Game.
Eines der besten Games aller Zeiten.
Ich sag's euch.
Äh, ja, wann schneit's denn hier?
Am 10.01.
Warum genau geht das
am 10.01. los?
Also, wenn wir Glück haben, schneit's,
schneit es morgen,
morgen und Montag,
Dienstag. Sollte das der Fall
sein, dann mach ich ein neues Gartenstellensvideo.
Saved.
So machen wir das Chat.
Das mach ich, aber es muss regnen.
Oder wenn's regnet, äh, nicht regnet,
es muss schneien.
Es muss schneien.
So.
Jetzt natürlich die große Preisfrage, Leute.
Wir haben noch ne Stunde Zeit. Was machen wir jetzt?
Ähm, ich muss
euch was
berichten.
Das Kamerastreaming-Programm,
was wir im Stream auch zusammenprogrammiert haben.
Das hat, glaub ich,
ne Memory-Leak.
Das kackt nämlich einmal am Tag ab,
weil's out of memory ist.
Obwohl die Kiste nicht
out of memory ist.
Also irgendwie hab ich da Mist
programmiert. Ich vermute, dass ich
irgendwas verkehrt gemacht hab,
dass ich zu viele Threads aufmache und die irgendwie
blockieren oder so.
Das war's,
Gloxalisa.
Reagiere doch auf, ich hab ein Jahr
lang alle Produktplatzierungen angenommen.
Okay, zeig mal.
Ich the Hacker-Mans.
Okay, zeig her.
Hat er das wirklich gemacht?
Man wird voll gespammt
as fuck.
Selbst ohne Scheiß, Leute,
selbst wenn ich inaktiv bin,
drei Jahre, ich krieg
immer noch sinnlosen China-Spam und
sonstige Dinger.
Ich liebe es, einen anderen
deutschen YouTube-Schöpfer zu sehen.
Ja, das ist normal.
Das ist normal.
Soll ich euch mal ein paar Mails
vorlesen, die bei mir gerade in der Inbox liegen?
Moment, machen wir mal.
Moment.
Eile.
Inbox.
Also.
Auszahlungsvergütung
für Oktober 2020.
Was ist denn mit Amazon los?
Ah, by the way,
Leute, ich muss mal gucken, was ich mit meinem
Produktplacement verdient habe.
Bei Amazon.
Nicht Produktplacement,
ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Mit meinem Reflink-Spam.
So, mal gucken.
Was habe ich damit?
Okay, das muss ich mal kurz nachgucken.
Na ja, fast 300,
kann man sich nicht beschweren.
Für eines der ersten Videos seit einem Jahr
oder so.
Ist doch in Ordnung,
kann man sich echt nicht beschweren.
Einfach mal so random?
Ist doch okay.
Stonks, alle richtig stonks.
Okay.
Ja, ich wollte euch Mails vorlesen, genau.
Also.
Max.
FPS-Mail.
Sponsored Stream Opportunity.
Ist das erste.
Hi Wubblors.
Oh, da bin ich ja immer begeistert.
Da bin ich immer begeistert,
wenn ich für Twitch
angeschrieben werde
und nicht für YouTube.
Immer richtig poggers.
Was will er denn?
Also, sein Name ist Philippe.
Er hat eine Sponsorship Opportunity.
Alles klar.
Also.
Das ist Karate-Rage Shadow Legends,
ich könnte wetten.
Also, der schreibt,
ein Game-Publisher,
die zusammenarbeiten,
ist interessiert, mit mir zusammen
eine Marketing-Kampagne zu starten
und ihr turn-based
Role-Playing-Game vor PC
zu promoten. Wobei vor PC
ist Rage Shadow Legends auch vor PC.
Ja, okay, okay. Dann das ist bestimmt
Rage Shadow Legends.
Ja, das ist Rage Shadow Legends.
Hört euch das mal an.
Ich meine, die drücken
schon ordentlich Kohle ab.
Also, wenn ich bereit dazu bin,
auch die weiteren Bonuses zu machen,
wahrscheinlich Ultra-Hulding
das Game oder sonst was,
gibt es die Kampagne
für 1050 Dollar.
Also, 1050,
also 1050 Dollar.
Fuck. Guckt euch mal
meinen Stream an, Alter. Kein Mensch guckt
meinen Stream. Und
so viel Kohle rücken die raus. Da seht ihr
mal, wie viel Geld man mit dem Kram verdient.
Ja, steuern das, klar. Ich mach das nicht,
Leute, aber das seht ihr mal.
Nee, so einen Kack will ich nicht
bewerben. Aber das seht ihr mal,
wie, ähm,
ja, guckt mal,
200. Leute,
ihr wisst, wie geil ich das finde, dass so viele
Leute zugucken, ja. Aber im Vergleich
zu anderen Streams ist das nix.
Aber eins, Chat, man muss
ja mal eins sagen,
also für das, dass ich nur
nur, ähm,
200 Leute zugucken,
ist hier im Chat immer gut was los und auch
Big Brain Time angesagt.
Aber überlegt euch das mal.
für ein 200-Mann-Stream.
Nee, nee, Patrick, das kannst du so nicht rechnen,
da gucken schon mehr.
Also ich hab pro Stream immer so um die,
die kommen
noch viel länger an, aber schon so
3000, 3500
Unique Viewer,
ja, also hier kommen schon recht, es sind
zwar auch immer die Stammzuschauer dabei, aber es
kommen im Stream auch schon immer
ne ganze Menge, ne ganze Menge durch,
ja.
Das sehen wir ja öfter, es kommen auch immer neue,
neue an Start.
Aber müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen, jetzt könnt ihr euch
überlegen, wenn die,
wenn die mir schon
um die 1000 Euro bieten
für, für mein Mini-Stream,
ja, dann überlegt euch mal,
was Leute, wir müssen jetzt
mal gar nicht von PewDiePie oder, oder
so gehen oder von Kronk oder sonst wem, aber
einfach nur Leute, die aktiv
sind und, und wirklich ein bisschen
was die für Geld kriegen,
ja.
Ok, nächste Mail.
Gewinne 1500
Euro in Games, verrückt
Ausrufezeichen.
Nehm jetzt am Gewinnspielteile,
ja, exellent, genau.
Last from Beyond
launches on
February 11th.
Small Christmas Gift
for content
creators oder sowas. Hä?
The fuck, was wollen die dann?
So, als nächstes kommt
der, der CEO,
oh ja, das, das find ich immer geil.
Wenn, wenn in Mail schon steht, dass
die Mail vom CEO kommt.
Da weißt du, da weißt du schon immer Bescheid, ja?
Also,
CEO
schreibt für die
Poligang Premiere.
What? Was ist das überhaupt?
Ein
Sandbox
World Action Game
im Low-Poly-Style, ok, das soll ich
bewerben, ok, jetzt gucken wir, jetzt gucken wir, was das ist.
Jetzt gucken wir, jetzt gucken wir mal,
für was wir Werbung machen sollen.
Fuck.
Ich hab's gelöscht.
Dabei wollte ich grad nen Tap aufmachen.
Monka. Ah, jetzt.
Äh.
Poligangs
auf Steam.
Ich geb da auch Steam dabei ein,
weil.
Ok.
Ach.
Ach, du Scheiße.
Kann man das Artstyle
nennen?
GTA
auf mich bestellt.
Aber RTX On.
So der Arti-Pose, ja.
Nur vom Feinsten.
Nur vom Feinsten, was man hier
bewerben soll.
Scheint auch wahnsinnig interessant
zu sein.
Aber
Scheint auch wahnsinnig interessant zu sein
für viele.
Ok. Also, was ist das nächste
wasch noch?
Tormentor.
Horror-Game.
Also ihr seht, man
kriegt
Also man
Man sieht, man kriegt auch, weil man nichts macht.
Ok.
Ok, sieht aus wie jedes 0815
Horror-Game.
Was ist schlecht?
Coming Soon.
Ah.
Ähm, Kamelo.
Ich bin echt der denkbar schlechteste,
äh, um dafür eine Bewertung abzugeben.
Ich hab's nicht gespielt.
Und sowohl Puppe,
als auch äh, andere so
auf realistisch gemachte Battle Royale.
Ich weiß, dass Escape vom Tarkov kein
richtig klassisches Battle Royale ist, aber es geht in die Richtung.
Ähm.
Ich kann ihr dazu wirklich nichts sagen.
Ich hab's bei Shroud ein paar Mal geguckt, da fand ich
spannend, aber das ist halt auch jemand, der das gut spielen kann.
Ich
kann mich da nicht
zu einem Urteil durchregen, ja.
Ich hab's nicht
gespielt.
So, also
ihr seht immer, man kriegt
auch als größter Kacknoob, wie ich,
der seit Jahren nichts auf YouTube
macht, kriegt so komische Anfragen
per Mail. Oh!
Das hab ich übersehen.
Der, äh, Killstreak-
Entwickler von dem Venice Unleashed Mod hat mich
angeschrieben. Dem muss ich noch
abonnieren.
Haha, das ist auch
geil! Haha, das muss ich euch
vorlesen.
Das muss ich euch vorlesen.
Vielleicht kann ich euch das auch kopieren.
Das muss ich euch
kopieren.
Geht schon gut los.
Ja.
Sehr geehrter Herr,
Nonolive ist eine
Kompliz- die Seite gucken wir uns jetzt
an. Anonym-Tab,
wobei,
ich weiß nicht, ob ich da draufgehen soll,
ehrlich gesagt.
Nee, ich geh da nicht drauf,
wer weiß, wo weiß, wo man da rauskommt.
Aus dem Markt rutscht das nicht, wo man andere
Live-Seiten zeigt, glaube ich zumindest.
Also, Nonolive ist eine
neue internationale Live-Übertragungsplattform
im Sitz, mit Sitz
in Hongkong, innerhalb der Dojo Group.
Die auf Nasseri, seit
1992 in unseren kleinen Betrieben, während
unsere Reichweite Millionen von Menschen in Asien
ausgehen und nun haben wir uns,
jetzt, jetzt kommt's, nun haben wir uns
auf den Weg gemacht, um einer der
Marktführer auf dem Spielemarkt in
Deutschland zu werden.
Auf diesem Weg bilden
wir ein Team,
in welchem wir mit professionellen
Produzenten von Inhalts-
und Inhaltskontrollen
in Deutschland sind.
Wenn Sie ein Teil dieses Teams
sein möchten, erwarten Sie eine
hohe Vergütung.
Ja, okay, Chance,
nimm Zahlen, haben Sie Interesse,
dann kontaktieren Sie uns doch gerne.
So, Scheiß kriegste da
mit.
Nee, also, okay, ich sollte
jetzt ja auf dieses Video hier
reacten, wie man so schon sagt, ich
reakte mal, also, auf geht's.
Megareaction.
Ja, gut,
wie gesagt, ich habe euch ja gerade gezeigt,
dass jeder Depp, also auch wie ich,
mittlerweile solche Mails bekommt, weil er
mal ein bisschen was auf YouTube gemacht hat.
Mit was?
Ja,
mit Sicherheit.
Battlefield Top Plays.
Wenn ich weiter striebe, kann ich sogar
ein Top Play Video machen, nur mit meinen Plays.
Ja, wie gesagt,
ich habe es euch ja gerade vorgelesen, so
Dinger kriegste, wirst du zugeschissen mit.
Ja,
ja,
wir sind so Dinger kriegste, wirst du zugeschissen mit.
Oah.
Die Dinger gibt es auch laufend.
Chloe der sich auf den bereich der damenprodukte spezialisiert hat und ein sich schnell entwickelndes unternehmen ist
unser unternehmen war schon immer um ihr youtube
besorgt
ehrlich gesagt wir finden ihnen sehr stylisch
wir sind der meinung was auch geil ist was auch was auch geil ist bei diesen bei diesen
Werbemails die kommen dann auch ja hallo ich bin es sind meistens frauen und meistens haben die ein
extrem hottes google profile pick dass du dass du direkt dass du direkt die mail aufmachst weil hier denkst
schreibt er eine mail
näher zumindest
Was was auch also so eine sache die auch in diesen mails immer drinne ist da stehen so was wie
Die hallo max ich bin schon ich bin schon lange fan von deinen videos oder wir
Wir schauen hier alle deine videos schon seit jahren gerne und sowas bla bla bla
bla bla bla
Freude bereiten kann und bei der breiten öffentlichkeit sehr beliebt ist
Es ist die netteste firma der welt wir denken also dass sie sich für unsere magnetischen wimpern
interessieren werden denn unsere wimpern die auke nicht verletzen es macht auch mehr spaß ich habe tatsächlich mehr spaß mit meinen wimpern wenn sie
Also meine wimpern verletzten die augenhaut auch selten
Also für mich ist das ein überzeugendes argument was mich dann nicht so überzeugt hat ist dass in der nächsten e-mail die nette franzi aus deutschland
plötzlich sind nichts zu klug
Wies warte mal wenn franzi gar nicht franzi heißt und auch gar nicht aus deutschland kommt was ist wirklich kann ich sein alles eine lüge
Hat sie vielleicht meine videos noch nie gesehen und dann dann weiß sie auch gar nicht ob ich wirklich stylish bin
Da nehme ich doch lieber die nächste anfrage an der betreff amazon
saki moon
Alexa staubsaugerroboter
Denen ich denen ich
Auch wenn die cloud down ist da kriege ich aber auch öfters anfragen von irgendwelchen china dinge man nicht produkte angucken will
Aber egal die wollen mir einfach kostenlosen staubsauger schicken wem habe ich das denn zu verdanken
Saki moon
Die e-mail ist abgesendet worden von
Saki
moon
gute tage ich bin ellen von emmery
Ich fand ein video auf
YouTube sehr schön und professionell unser produkt staubsaugerroboter verkaufen wir bei amazon
Link wir hoffen dass sie dieses produkt auf blog news rank jo tobe facebook twitter testen
Die mail sind halt so
Können um es zu bestrafen
Ist ein beutel schon wieder voll du schmutz fink
Die melden sind aber halt wirklich so
Oder haben sie andere anforderungen wir wissen dass sie viele fans haben die solche produkte ja ok aber jetzt muss er mal langsam zum punkt kommt gerne bewerten beste community danke dass ihr mir kostenlose staubsaugerroboter ermöglicht ich habe einfach mal zurückgeschrieben
Vielen dank für ihre antwort bald ja sie haben mehr als 200.000 fans die sehr nett sind
Beste community ich hoffe sie können bei unserem amazon bestellen und uns eine fünf sterne bewertung
Moment wie warum soll der bestellen
Ist das scam ist das scam
Ist das scam
Akzeptieren sie das nein ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt nicht so sicher ob ich saki moonen verkaufen sollte dass ich mein geld auch zurück bekomme ich bewerbe mich für das kostenlose produkt für das video von chef brauche aber zeit sie bestellen bei amazon schneller ich habe natürlich nichts da bestellt aber dann hat der chef anscheinend meine 200.000 netten fans gesehen
Ich würde ich würde ohne scheiß das würde ich auch im leben nicht machen die sollen das ich gehe doch da nicht in vorkasse hallo
Die haben mich einfach so geschickt
Da ist er
Jetzt kann ich auch endlich unabhängige tests für blognews rank youtube facebook oder twitter machen wo auch immer ich lust drauf hab
Verkaufsargument unter dem video hinzufügen 145 grad navigationssensor mit visuellem slam
Mit was
A 900 wieder Alexa saugroboter staubsauger
Der video titel der video titel ist exakt so wie aliexpress die seiten immer heißen
Ich dachte das soll unabhängig sein und jetzt wollen die mir sogar vorschreiben wie ich das video natürlich und wisst ihr was passiert wisst ihr was passiert wenn du das nicht machst
Die heulen dir übelst einen vor
So nach dem motto mein chef entlässt mich wenn ich ihm im monat nicht mindestens zehn erfolge vorzuweisen habe und sowas die machen dann die machen dann übelst auf
Drehendrüse wenn du das nicht machst weil was anderes können sie ja nicht machen wird doch nie jemand so machen oder
Ja klar klar natürlich ich mein guckt euch mal diese komischen
Diese komischen channels an ich mein lohnt sich das für den hersteller wirklich
Ok worum geht es heute was ihr euch bestimmt denken könnte wenn man youtube videos macht oder generell influencer oder influencerin ist
Ja ich meine überlegt mal leute guckt mal ich habe auf youtube die letzten sechs jahre
So gut wie nix gemacht guck mal ich kann relativ easy einfach mal zurückscrollen und dann sind wir bei sechs jahren ja easy
Also gut ich habe ein bisschen was danach gemacht aber im vergleich zu anderen ist das nicht so viel ja so und
Sogar ich krieg vielleicht nicht täglich aber relativ oft so ein kack also jemand der wirklich da grad voll im saft ist auf youtube
Das war früher dein content pro jahr ja ungefähr
Von dir wollen manche sind seriös und manche sind die 500. Anfrage für rate shadow legends ja die hatte ich auch schon
Die hatte ich auch schon
Wundert euch nicht ja macht es möglich dass man so tut
Ja nicht auch schon ja was ich habe gesagt habe alle place angenommen wundert euch nicht ja macht es möglich dass man so tut
Ich kann zum beispiel auf webseiten zugreifen die für bestimmte regionen gesperrt sind zum beispiel
Ich war einfach jetzt auch ich habe auch eine vpn das mache ich jetzt auch ich habe auch warte mal ich gucke mal moment wo mit leute ich gucke mal
Ich habe nämlich auch eine vpn anfrage gekriegt
Hallo warum geht sanderburt nicht auf
Leute sanderburt ist gecrashed
Nee
Meine startleiste ist gecrashed was ist das
Moment moment ich muss mal kurz gucken vpn ich hatte doch letztens auch irgendein vpn typ am start hier
Ich suche einfach mal vpn
Surf shark wollte
Surf shark ok was ist surf shark
Surf shark
Ok so ein vpn ding alles klar heute ich mache surf shark werbung jetzt easy
Angebote die es vielleicht nur in den usa gibt man kann so auch bei spielen auf server anderer länder zugreifen
Was manchmal echt praktisch ist zum beispiel für mitternachts releases so eine vpn kann auch dazu beitragen
Dass man seinen weg und seine daten im internet etwas mehr versteckt in dem ist die daten verschlüsselt und die ip adresse
verbirgt
Ich finde aber eins muss man sagen er trägt das immer noch seriöser vor als der bauer der bauer macht diese placements immer immer richtig top
Genauso wird die placements wahrscheinlich auch machen
Der ratter das immer so richtig so richtig uninteressiert runter genauso musst du es machen bis zu sechs geräten gleichzeitig nutzbar aktuell bekommt ihr es mit dem code und unter nord vpn.com ab 3 euro 15 pro monat und aktuellen kriegt man auch noch vier kostenlose monate gratis dazu außerdem gibt es eine 30 tage geld zurückgarantie wenn ihr es also testen wollt könnt ihr es einfach mal ausprobieren link ist in der video beschreibung
Ich habe ein jahr lang auf jede anfrage geantwortet ich habe herauszufinden was dahinter steckt und wie viele dieser seltsamen produkte ich tatsächlich zugeschickt bekomme das hier ist die ausbeute von ein jahr
also wer mir ja wirklich leid tut ist der von den modmics weil der modmics typ der hat mich gefragt ob ich das haben will weil er hat gesehen dass ich mal ein video drüber gemacht habe über das alte modmics da habe ich gesagt ja klar würde ich gerne ausprobieren und der hat mich fünfmal angeschrieben ob ich nicht ob ich nicht mal wenigstens im video was zu sagen kann und das war die die phase wo ich keinen bock hatte videos zu machen und der war dann glaube ich ein bisschen angepisst dass er mir eins geschickt hat und ich habe nie irgendwie auch noch was zu sagen
ich habe einfach nur einmal einen satz zugesagt
jo schick mal ich habe ausgerechnet der wahrenwert zusammen ist ungefähr bei 850 euro in diesem haufe hier gibt es ein highlight das war die beste anfrage meiner infanzkarriere
besser gesagt s y 0 x ff ja ja dann hat er das routing verkackt von djentjen djentjen einfach einfach nur dir ja gut sehr geehrter herr hatten wir eben
ok ok mal ernsthaft
unabhängig davon ob man auf so was steht oder nicht wer würde also wer wer steckt sich so ein china ding in the bobs
wer steckt sich so ein china ding in the bobs da musst du ja angst haben dass du danach irgendwelche komischen bakterien oder irgendwelche komischen keime oder sonst was hast
ne
er kann dich schön abbremsen
natürlich natürlich ist das denn egal das juckt immer absolut gar nicht
dass ich strumpfhosen trage frauenkleidung dass ich keine tattoos habe und auch keine semi permanenten testen möchte auch nicht von einem tattoo auf dem angeblich dann bad girl steht ich habe hier so diese wimpern bekommen wo sie offensichtlich wake up wake up beschrieben haben die marke heißt aber makeup wake up also haben sie das einfach durchgestrichen ich habe eine uhr bekommen hier schön in gold einfach so ja ein handy halter gummi bärchen die nach apfelessig
dieses fette handy was offensichtlich irgendwie was das ist eine powerbank oder das ist kein handy und kaputt bar machbar sein soll und vier random smart glühbirnen das creepy an dieser box ist die haben wir vorher keine email geschrieben wir haben nachdem wir den anderen meine adresse geschickt haben irgendwann plötzlich auch das bekommen wahrscheinlich weil ich irgendwo jetzt in der datenbank stehe okay aber warum machen die unternehmen das eine sache die ich festgestellt habe ist dass 90 prozent der produkte die wir
bekommen haben und auch der leute die sie uns geschickt haben aus china stammt klar vermute um damit im westlichen markt fuß zu fassen die haben allerdings kein budget und die meisten die sache ist aber auch so die haben auch kaum versandkosten das halt subventioniert bis zum geht nicht mehr ist so ein bisschen postata massage nicht genug bezahlung richtiges influencer marketing kostet mehrere tausende oder zehntausende euro das können die sich nicht leisten und das finde ich unfair
deswegen hat dieses video ab jetzt untertitel in simplify chinese ja ich habe das video übersetzen lassen das ist das minste was ich tun kann als gegenleistung für die kostenlosen sachen dass die endlich mitgucken können die offensichtlich noch nie t-beutel dankeschön plus eins iq für den chat wieder von mir vorher angeguckt haben ich habe jedes die wollen aber auch ja es ist spickert das das habe ich mir auch gerade gesagt die wollen aber auch dass wenn du auf youtube gehst und ein gibst günstig staubsauger robot
die wollen dass ihr ding halt dabei auftaucht unten verlinkt guckt es euch an hälften netten menschen die doch nur in deutschland ihren postata anal dildo promoten wollen damit die menschheit glücklich wird jetzt wird das video bestimmt immer interessiert
egal das video kostet mich eh unendlich viel geld denn ich habe beschlossen diese netten menschen die mir ihr vertrauen geschenkt haben und einer wild fremden personen die eine fremde sprache spricht und auf dem anderen kontinent wurde einfach ihr wertvolles produkt geschickt haben in hoffnung dass sie vielleicht glück haben und ein bisschen influencer marketing bekommen diesen menschen gebe ich etwas für ihr blindes vertrauen zurück was hoffentlich ihre kühnsten
erwartungen übertrifft da hat es jetzt den kram angezogen aus china oder was von aliexpress jawoll
sei ich eine coole idee das ist echt gut gemacht
wir möchten dass die menschen glücklich sind und es alles genießen dank unserer patentierten blatt technologie und rigorosen tests im windkanal können wir unseren neuen zahnrad vibrations motor nun im teufelskreis der lust mit abs zertifizieren
kennst du dich aus was man auf youtube nicht sagen darf oder sonst demonetarisiert wird nein das weiß keiner so genau weil youtube die richtlinien alle ein bisschen vage hat ja also es gibt ein paar sachen die darfst du mit sicherheit nicht sagen das ist alles was illegal ist auch in deutschland ja da gibt es ja ein paar dinger aber ansonsten ist schon ein bisschen random was du aber was du aber sagen darfst
ist gerade dabei sind nicht das was mit dem video was du sagen darfst ist das darfst du sagen
kennen sie das sie wollen mal wieder ihren staubsauger bestrafen weil er nicht hoffentlich hat er die antworten von den chinesen auch drinnen nicht zu der a 900 wlan alexa saugroboter staubsauger roboter roboter staubsauger mit 145 navigationssensor mit visuellem slam der ist dsg v o konform er kann sogar mehr müll speichern als die meisten auf dem markt kann
dir sogar mehr müll speichern als youtube das ist ja ein exzellenter staubsauger ist das schlecht
massive kicks
ich hoffe ich habe ich hoffe er hat auch hinten um den bros tatre am start
ich hoffe diese werbespots haben ihre erwartungen übertroffen die unternehmen erwarten übrigens jetzt auch dass ihr
die produkte gerne bewerten haben sie ja gesagt 200.000 nette menschen die produkte gerne bewerten also wenn ihr amazon bewertung schreiben wollt wie toll
ist und dass man ihm viele produkte schicken soll wird euch keiner aufhalten ich schulde saki moon ja auch noch eine fünf sterne bewertung stimmt das muss ich ja muss ich muss ich ja
saki moon ja also ich fände es cool wenn man auch die antworten von den chinesen gesehen hätte falls die überhaupt antworten
excellent
das video ist wirklich nicht schlecht
poggers
heute noch zwanzig minuten
noch zwanzig minuten bis 2020 remastered
oder zwanzig zwanzig ti ich hätte übrigens gar nicht gedacht dass mein lowprane meme so gut ankommt guckt euch an einfach 543
herzchen ich habe nichts anderes gemacht als das meme einfach in deutsche zeit umgewandelt das habe ich mir noch nicht mal ausgedacht
der witz ich habe mir noch nicht mal den witz ausgedacht ich habe einfach nur das deutsche datumsformat genommen
jetzt wird er noch professioneller mima das ist er schon lang
dr. pepper cherry oder dr. pepper ist dr. pepper nicht das was so nach nach gummi bärchen nach irgendwie aufgelösten gummi bärchen schmeckt
oder verwechsel ich das jetzt was mountain dew dr. penny das war dr. pepper ist immer so immer ist alles ist alles eklig
ach ne warte mal red bull schmeckt nach gummi bärchen ach was sag immer trinkt das alles nicht das ist wirklich das ich bin leute ich bin pepo fett genug ja aber den kram trinke ich nicht und esse ich nicht und sowas
ab ab zu cobalt transpiler in c++ ja ganz bestimmt einmal im monat wird die dose gegönnt exzellent es gibt sogar wagen die das gewicht twitteren kann man ohne probleme selbst machen ich habe eine waage die kann man per bluetooth abgreifen und da könnt ihr ohne probleme twitteren aber will ich wirklich twitteren jedes mal wenn ich mich auf die waage stelle
ist das sebaro da wo ist er da ist er ja sebaro was sagst du dazu was sagst du dazu wie findest du das belldelfin video um die wichtigen sachen gleich mal zu klären
ich weiß dass du das gesehen hast du kannst mir nicht sagt mir nicht du hast das nicht gesehen das glaube ich dir mehr als du erwartet ernsthaft ich fand das richtig schlecht das schlechteste schlechteste porno aller zeiten alle war das hast du das auf dem discord gesehen kann sein aber irgendwas war da ja aber ich hab's wieder verdrängt
ne das kann ich jetzt nicht gucken es ist gleich 19 minuten ist soweit
der typ hat sich mehrmals geleakt ja gut was interessiert mich was das für ein typ ist
kennst du reveal js ja sag mir was blutwitz der typ war max ich alles verraten alter wo wupp liegt
ne wupp liegt ist es ja nur habt ihr eigentlich schon gesehen was wir für nice neue emotes haben seht ihr das hier wir haben jetzt wupp liegt wupp prime und wupp boom guckt euch das mal an sind die nicht poggers
was ein tier 3 sup wo es ein tier 3 sup
ach so ich selbst alter chat jebaitet mich nicht so ich dachte ich dachte ich dachte ich hab irgendwas übersehen ja sebaro das wünscht ihr mit sicherheit der ganze chat auch
aber es haben keine nice emotes übrigens ne diese emotes die ich vorher schon drinne hat die werden wir aber kurz oder lang wahrscheinlich raus machen wobei wupp wupp also wupp s behalten war das ist cool den rest hab ich ja nur mehr oder weniger ein bisschen verändert von betta twitch tv geklaut
flow 690 14 monat 14 monat das ist ja schon das ist ja schon hyper subscription wupp lull ist auf betta twitch tv ja ich weiß
ich weiß aber ich hab es ein bisschen geändert wir brauchen gescheite keks emotes ja willst du sagen also den da find ich cool ich find die eigentlich alle nice ja ist dein anime text to speech public ne du meinst das hier ne das ist nicht public
das muss nicht sein das ist dann das dann wupp wupp gassum könnte man machen wobei so so ein gassum emote braucht jeder wir brauchen auch noch generell
lull nen lull nen pock und nen gassum emote ja ja muss sein wupp aiya ja könnte man eigentlich auch machen cute cute keks machen wir dann wupp cute da brauchen wir irgendeinen keks mit so roten bäckchen oder sowas
nice gute idee excellent
mario sunshine exquisite und 15 minuten noch
sowas in der richtung ja das wäre sehr lustig aber das passt nicht das muss der keks an sich irgendwie sein
wupp ko ball ne ne ne das machen wir nicht das machen wir über fiverr das machen wir über fiverr hier was jetzt los das gem train 15 minuten vor mitternacht das gem train ist am start leute du hast nur wenig zeit
morgen gibt es nix mehr leute letzte chance zusammen dieses jahr
wir hatten gesagt pro gaming sebi ein sechsmonat dankeschön iq plus plus subscription hast du das neue video von boston dynamics gesehen nein habe ich nicht
aber ist es fußballmusik aber iq plus plus keller kind zwei monate dankeschön und dominic 5341 auch zwei monate double subscription hier
ja manchmal muss man manchmal muss man einfach durchziehen ja
beste sammel nice das haben wir in der vorschau top abonniert jetzt nur so lange der vorrat reich plot fester ja wisst ihr was passiert wisst ihr was passiert wenn
der hype train auf level 5 level 100 ist da geht es einfach weiter auf 125 which she baitet euch gnadenlos was das angeht ja das hört gar nicht mal auf
level was level 5050 prozent das war bestimmt irgendein asmr e grill alter part jetzt über drei paltmar pock was denn hier los 25 25 milliarden mehr
poggers ai ai ai ai ai ai 25 abos verschenkt wer hat denn wer hat ein glück wer hat was gekriegt tax
h n 3 s 1 meckel klaus körper bester namen die shocks krate will hell crocodile und i 88
editor nick toxics niedersachs 1 nietach nie niedersachs 1 wonder punkt mccabin loki turner elaine zz nun da runo exquisite aussprache
johannes elmond olm krank user kopf viel die q 18 don't cry so much crux terror kicks 490 der stubenhocker 5 und natürlich der allseits beliebte
xt xd xd xd xt xd xd xt xd xd ddi doch das war natürlich ganz besonders wichtig was der noch eingekriegt hat dann Shi für die ganzen
subs und jetzt sind wir beim halbetsticks 5 256 prozent 256 wirksme Yue zahle suppliers
Hä, ich habe den Namen vorgelesen. Warum ist es jetzt 257? 256 war viel besser
Habe ich jeden vergesst
Hotgamergrill69 hoh jetzt wäre ich aber ganz nervös bei dem sub
Jetzt jetzt wird es aber oh oh oh
Hotgamergrill69 als subscript, dankeschön für den primes up plus 1 IQ hier
Kriegst du jetzt neue Emotes? Ich habe so viele Emotes noch offen die
Ich habe 28 Emote Slots und wir haben gerade aktuell 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 Emotes
Also ich habe noch 21 Emote Slots offen. Habe ich jeden vergessen vorzulesen?
Ne oder? Ich glaube ich habe alle vorgelesen
Das wäre natürlich nice. Hype Trane Success Leute, das teilen wir die ganzen Emotes
Massive ja
Der Twitch Chat blickt nicht mal durch, also hier Twitch blickt nicht mal durch
Soll ich noch was sagen? Ich finde diese ganzen Hype Trane Emotes zacken zum größten Teil
richtig
Obei Leute also die geilsten Emotes gibt es im Hype Trane natürlich versteht
sich. Ich muss mir mal angewöhnen ein bisschen mehr Sellout zu machen
Ich mache kaum any Primers, ich mache kaum Sellout, ich mache kaum irgendwelche
Subgoals oder sonst was ja. Twitch hat eine Fiverr Type 5 Euro geben
Aha
So Leute gleich haben wir es geschafft. Gleich ist 2020 TI oder 2020 Remastered
wie auch immer man das will. Und soll ich euch noch was sagen? 2021 fängt genau so
an wie 2020 aufgehört hat. Massive weiß halt ich weiß
So langsam setzt sich auch mein Pepo fett. Ich bin zwar immer noch übelst voll
gefressen aber so langsam geht's. In sechs Minuten ist Corona zu Ende
ne ne ne ne ne ne das stimmt nicht. In sechs Minuten kommt die Bahn pünktlich. Ne aber
das Corona in sechs Minuten vorbei es kann nicht sein Corona war ja offiziell
glaube schon Mitte November vorbei. Kann euch daran erinnern ich habe extra
getwittert als das beschlossen wurde so nach dem Motto was ein Schwachsinn man
den Leuten erzählen will und es wurde verlängert und wieder verlängert und
wieder verlängert war ja klar irgendwo. Du kannst nicht einfach aufhören. Corona
2.0 Release in sechs Minuten. Face reveal bei 1000 Subs ok ok chat chat aber nicht
so einfach. Face reveal wenn ich es schaffe über ein halbes Jahr 1000 Subs zu
halten. Das wird ein bisschen schwierig ja
ja ich kann auch kaum die Nano-Ropoter aus der Impfung erwarten oder was auch
immer wieder nach kriegen ja. Lass es 500 sein ne 500 sind ja realistisch
ich mache doch keine realistischen Goals da muss ich das ja noch wirklich
machen. Doobie die 10 Monate danke für den Sub. Wie viel hast du gerade? Ich denke
mal um die 300 jetzt nach heute. Ja Flo690 macht das. Und der gleiche ist soweit wir
brauchen eine richtige. Welche Webseite ist denn gut? JS clock oder world clock github
gibt es doch bestimmt. Ich brauche eine gute Urseite ohne Werbung.
Ne. World clock free without ads. Was? PTB? Ah excellent.
Clock. Habe ich cock geschrieben? Inkompatibler Zustand.
Gleich ist es soweit. Wie das besser ist als der als der als der Android
der Timepicker. Ich muss dann übrigens in in drei Minuten nach dem 2020 TI los
geht mal kurz rüber einmal einmal anstoßen und ich trinke da nix und gehe
wieder rüber also ich muss zumindest so tun als beteilige ich mich ein wenig an
sozialen Events abweichung was ist abweichung
oh nein 149 millisekunden 173 233 wird ja immer mehr
da müssen wir prädikten und schon im Vorfeld. Wo ist das Java
scripting exzellent
ok wir sind gerüstet die beste silvester tradition ist der stream ja
nice wenn es dir gefällt dass ich habe ja heute eigentlich nichts gemacht im
stream außer dummes zeug erzählt du kannst ja mit uns anstoßen ich trinke
aber ich ja doch hier ex ex exquisite ich habe hier mein mein saft
yes
orange saft nein stimm ich frühstück saft heißt deswegen eine mischung
warum geht meine uhr so viel so falsch leute es ist so weit monka es 2020 startet
jetzt exzellent messer poggers ja
chat
schön dass er ein jahr lang hier war exzellent ich gucke mal kurz auf meine auf
meine kamera außen ob irgendwie leute feuerwerk machen man guckt nicht aus dem
fenster ich gucke einfach ich gucke einfach die kamera ok leute wollt ihr
wollt ihr mal wollt ihr mal vor mein hoftor gucken mit der kamera da muss
euch mal kurz ausmachen dass ich nur die einzelne kamera aufmachen kann
die seite geht nicht ja und jetzt kommt die zee vorbei fack jetzt sieht man
nichts ok ich kann euch nichts zeigen leute ich kann ich kann euch nichts
zeigen also bei uns wenn ich so rausgucke es ist ein bisschen was aber zum größten
teil hält sich den grenzen das ist es ist kaum was ist es nicht viel ok ich
gehe jetzt mal kurz rüber mache l anstoß action dann komme ich da wieder
da
meint ihr in köln machen sie jetzt all die lichter an und aus ich habe gelesen
dass in köln die leute um 23 uhr alle ihre lichter ihre lichter an und aus
machen sollen für feuerwerk ersatz kein witz wirklich ernsthaft die
stadtwerke freuen sich wahrscheinlich
96 na ganz so ist es nicht
übrigens hier ich habe jetzt sogar ein bisschen bisschen sekt am start ich hab
kein stück ich habe kein klassekt in die hand gedrückt bekommen nicht nicht dass
ich das wollte aber chat chat cute chat excellent exquisite basically trunk
stream die sache ist die ich vertrag gar nichts weil ich trinke ja normalerweise
nie was wenn ich ein klasseck trinke ich merke dass instant was eigentlich total
fail ist bei meiner bei meiner masse ja das sollte ich normalerweise nix merken
aber ich bin so wenig gewöhnt dass ich trotzdem was merke
excellent ob ich sie ein bisschen mehr halbmusik hier
die abweichung ist klein ich glaube der hat gerade zeit gestellt kann das sein
der hat der hat gerade ein tp ist aber abgerufen windows logik ja loki fall ist
echt so wenn man ganz jahr über nix gewöhnt ist ich weiß ja nicht wie das
bei dir ist also wenn wie oft du das machst ja aber ich trinke alles ganz
ja immer gar nix und dann ab und zu mal an weihnachten silvester ein bisschen was
schmeckt instant sofort
96 ja die anderen merken es bei mir meistens später als ich selbst
ich habe ich habe so was ganz merkwürdig ist wenn ich nicht so
richtig besoffen bin sondern sondern nur so nur ein bisschen ich fange an
schlechter zu hören ich habe keine ahnung woran das liegt andere leute
fangen an zu wackeln oder so ich höre schlechter ganz merkwürdig also ich
könnte kein ich könnte dann kein battlefield spielen oder so ich bin alt ja
aber sonst höre ich ja normal
also hier ist nix hier ist nix es sind vorhin zwei drei raketen hochgeflogen
rest war es war nix ich muss ja mein leds anmachen auf auf feuerwerk
in der schweiz ist es erlaubt ja siehste
bangfurt ist gerade stark bombardiert also hier geht's bangfurt ist ja aber normal
ich könnte mir vorstellen leute dass im osten tatsächlich mehr ist weil im
osten sind die allen nach polen gefahren habe ich polen böller geholt
jetzt
ja was kann ich sagen ich finde es nice dass so viele leute am start sind das
ganze jahr über am start gewesen sind auf twitch man darf ja nicht vergessen
dass ich auf twitch zum größten teil jetzt nicht gerade so mainstream kram
macht wir programmieren irgendwelche sachen wir basteln irgendwelche
raspberry pie geschichten wir spielen games die neun jahre alt sind oder so
was in der richtung zumindest welfi 3 ist absolut nicht mainstream wir haben
cobalt programmiert was ich selbst nicht gedacht hätte dass wir so ein kack mal
machen und auf youtube diesen monat war auch
nice wieder richtig viele neue leute dabei gekommen auch ein paar videos
gehabt die auch algorithmus mäßig gut angekommen sind jetzt ist nur die große
preisfrage chat oder leute die große preisfrage ist ob ich es 2021 hin
bekomme mich zu motivieren und weiterzumachen
das ist die große preisfrage ich habe es vor aber das hat weiß schon
bescheid alle ich habe es vor aber ihr kennt mich es könnte aber aus einem
grund tatsächlich diesmal funktionieren weil ich will endlich 300k aber es auf
youtube haben und wenn das so weiter geht wie jetzt habe ich das in paar
monaten und ich habe homeoffice dankorona
hot but shady drei monat dankeschön für den sub huge subscription
aber max bei einem million abos musst du doch face reveal machen ja aber ich
krieg keine 1 million abos in nächster zeit was willst du sonst den ganzen tag
machen was anderes ich habe es ja auch die letzten sechs
jahre geschafft was zu machen ohne viele videos zu machen ja ich weiß gar nicht
wo die sylvaner klar ist das letzte mal wo ich was von der von von von der
sylvaner gehört habe da ist sie glaube ich gerade irgendwie nach england
ausgewandert ich weiß nicht wie das jetzt mit brexit aussieht kein schimmer
ja bis ich eine million hat da bin ich opa fps
wer ist die sylvaner eigentlich das ist jemand mit der der friseur und ich früher
öfters mal auf der xbox gespielt haben
sie ließ sempai heißt die auf xbox live weiß ich bis heute noch ich weiß auch
nicht ein paar sachen merkt man sich irgendwie ja das ist richtig lang her
ja zwar so 2011 oder so ungefähr da wo das sika unboxing video gemacht haben
übrigens wisst ihr dass der friseur auch wieder videos macht auf youtube
im gleichen zug hat der friseur ja auch aus spaß gemeint wir machen ihnen
schwingt in schmink video aber da hat er sich bisher auch immer vorgedrückt
irgendwie das neueste videos eineinhalb stunden monster sanctuary ohne hat gute
belichtung hat sich elgato stream light dinger gekauft
näro serone tja selbst schuld selbst schuld
ob ich ja mal ehrlich sagen muss bisschen übertrieben ist an manchen
stellen schon zum beispiel war ich vorgestern oder so im rewe einkaufen
und da stand ein schild man soll sobald man den parkplatz betrittene maske aufziehen
oder parkplatz ist riesengroß da ist nicht viel los gewesen und die leute sind
im freien also ja man kann es auch übertreiben aber zum größten und zum
größten und ganzen kann ich das alles nachvollziehen und ergibt auch ergibt
auch das meist irgendwo noch ein bisschen sinn ja außerdem ist das beste beim
live stream da kann er prinzipiell nichts passieren
grewe ist das nicht was für grewe verdiener was ok wo gehen denn die high
society big brain rolex träger hin
netto norma all dann auch mal gehts nicht mehr edeka edeka war ich davor im edeka
war ich vorm rewe und beim edeka muss man auf dem parkplatz keine maske anziehen
und bei der sache ist er die ich bestelle seit jahren 90 prozent das sachen außer
lebensmittel bei amazon amazon und online aber von online auch 90 prozent amazon
ich habe ehrlich jetzt jetzt jetzt nicht ich für den stream aus ich habe die
letzten zehn jahre nichts mehr im mediamarkt oder saturn oder irgendwo in
dem oft in dem offline elektronikladen gekauft
das einzige was ich mir kaufen wollte aber was sie nicht da haben war für
engl ein bastelprojekt beim konrad auf der zeil was die haben viel da aber das
teil hatten sie nicht da ich war ich überlegte was ich wollte ich glaube in
einem magne in spezieller magnet sensor oder irgendwie so was in hatten sie
kann ich am start
oder heute pepo fett setzt wieder ein pepo fett setzt wieder ein ich werde
wieder müde die uhr hat einen ping ja da weiß man bescheid das heißt du kannst
jetzt ein gehirn kalibrieren darauf dass der zeiger ein bisschen langsamer geht
einmalig jetzt immer noch voll ja bei mir hat jetzt auch einer jetzt wieder
vorbei eben ist aber gerade eine rakete hochgeflogen bei mir hat auch einer
eben angefangen wieder hier aber ist so gut wie nix
ein super schurke ein was für ein ding das ist doch unter der haupe auch noch
china kram mit exquisite logo anzibel puppet oder chef anzibel
beste frage beste frage für erste erste 0015 chef anzibel oder puppet
alles klar weil weil ich finde dass das von der sündags her und vom aufbau her
irgendwie am logischsten ist puppet ist wir wir haben ganz viel puppet auf der
arbeit puppet ist wir das ist puppet ist halt fast nur deklarativ was bei
server konflikt nicht immer gut ist du willst halt oftmals auch sagen reinfolge
und schleife und sonst was ich weiß das geht ein puppet auch alles ein bisschen
komplizierter ich da finde ich sowohl von der sündags her auch wie es war
ehrlich gesagt anzibel am wenigsten schlecht
chef habe ich kaum was gemacht
chat wollen wir morgen aufwacht stream machen wobei ich weiß gar nicht ob ich
das hinkriege penne bestimmt morgen bis 10 die kfc konsole ja die habe ich
gesehen die kfc konsole mit hähnchenwärmer
richtig poggers
moment was passiert wenn ich hier auf die auf auf lautstärke drück
sprachausgabe aktiviert und jetzt beim nächsten piep ist es 017 und 30
sekunden ok den will brauche ich keiner ok jetzt jetzt werde ich den chat alle
die nicht aufpassen werde ich jetzt mal schocken schocken
das ist fies ja ich weiß das ist fies
das ist in 16 d 3d reicht nicht
jetzt hat noch ein anderer typ angefangen raketen stell zu machen gerade
weiß das ganze muss man gleich gucken was die katzen treibt
war das kopfhörer ich habe auch kopfhörer was klopfhörer ja
was ein bio vision eclipse ok klingt klingt schon mal exquisite klingt so
klingt so als müsste das teuer sein ich bin ja ich bin ja eigentlich nicht
sonderlich geizig aber ich weiß es hört sich jetzt widersprüchlich an aber ich
gebe ungern geld für unsinnige sachen aus so so also ich habe keinen schmerz
damit wenn ich was kauf mir was richtig gutes zu kaufen zum beispiel auch
irgendwie ein ordentliches audio interface oder sowas aber einfach nur
geld ausgeben um geld auszugeben da habe ich keinen bock drauf
rakete an einem fenster explodiert monka ist eigentlich man kann ja sein dass
der übelst geiles der fernseher also ja stin bei mir ist kaum was
es bei mir sind es vielleicht insgesamt vielleicht fünf raketen oder so
rumgeflogen also es ist wenig also im vergleich zu
letzten jahren ist extrem wenig
bei euch werden im sekundentakt böller geht so ne hier ist kaum was hier wohnen
halt die gescheiten leute bei mir die haben auch schon alle was von von von
der chat iq steigerung abgekriegt
böllern ist nicht verboten zu zu verkaufen war verboten
kommt im neuen jahr endlich stark wer interessiert denn starcraft noch 2020
20 20 te ja stimmt habe ich vergessen
stark öft ist nice ja aber es kommt kaum also stark auf zwei kocht kaum noch
einer selbst die koreaner sind wieder ein bisschen darauf zurückgeschwänkt
stark öft 1 zu gucken stark öft 2 ist auch so ein ding was blitz hat ein bisschen
verkackt hat aber nix gegen overwatch in overwatch liegt aber fange ich jetzt
aber nicht von an den 20 20 die chalk ne da ist jetzt schon ausgelutscht
ja die auch tbe ne das ist ja jetzt schon ausgelutscht genauso wie 2020
remastered außerdem wissen wir alles heißt gar nicht 2020 und 2021 sondern
das heißt 2k 21 bitteschön ja 2k 21 in 2021 lull weh schuh lull lull weh größer
keck weh alles klar leute stellt euch vor diesen satz den ich gerade von mir
gegeben habe sagt ein 36 jähriger typ um 0 22 auf 20 der vor seinem recht an
einbockt
bates jam aber richtig 2021 und corona immer noch da er ist auch saurei dass
ich das corona sich dafür interessiert
während dem an partige feiern ist nix hier ist nix es ist es ist zehn
kopf am ab es ist so ruhig wie wie normale nacht es ist nix 36 lull ja ich
mache jetzt ziemlich genau zehn jahre youtube oder mache youtube bin auf
youtube machen tue ich ja wenig in letzter zeit er bei euch knallt
anscheinend für mich mit weil wie gesagt bei mir ist nix oder ein splatoon
geht sofort das platoon muss ich schrecklich danach korona kommt mutiert es korona
was auch witzig ist das hat ja einmal jetzt im kreis aus china irgendwo hier
her nach england oder so dann mutiert und dann jetzt ist es wieder in china
zurück dass ich einmal im kreis ich meine warum müssen die chinesen auch
irgendwelche fledermäuse fressen zwar ernsthaft können sie sich einfach sein
lassen wenn es kein korona
die sind eh hart drauf die fordern alles
ich weiß jetzt so eine fledermaus selbst selbst komplett frittiert ist das übelst
eklig da sind wir ja noch heuschrecken in afrika lieber als fledermäuse
siehst du die veganer können jetzt sagen wenn sie alle veganer wäre es auch
nicht passiert ja es hat schon ein bisschen was von manchen resident evil
games das stimmt nur mit dem unterschied dass die leuten
nichts aus keine komischen tentakel aus dem kopf wachsen außer in manchen
manchen in manchen film ist das so aber in echt nicht noch nicht
face reveal ja wie gesagt face reveal entweder bei einer million youtube
abos oder wenn ich über 1000 subs auf twitch über ein halbes jahr haben easy
das pokemon musik könnte sogar sein ja passt ja irgendwie auch
aktive subs bei einer million bin ich auch also einer million euro bin ich auch dabei
kann es mir auf mein only fan only fans account überweisen aber bei wobei ich
bin ich ich bin ich so über paypal nämlich auch und dann mache ich noch
rate shadow legends placement und dann easy money
marx hast längst sein gesicht gezeigt habe ich auch schon es gibt ein paar
videos da sieht man mich drin es hat irgendwie kaum einer gecheckt
arena ernsthaft das gibt es doch schon ewig sind das überhaupt noch jemand
interessiert
ne katz ist nicht unterm bett bei mir ist kaum was
also leute ich würde sagen wir machen morgen aufwacht stream ich probiere es
zumindest gucken wann ich wach bin wir machen jetzt schluss hier gibt ja
eh nix was sinnvolles zu machen besauft euch nicht zu sehr
gibt es irgendjemanden hosten können der friseur am start ne glaube ich nicht
oder sonst keine am start genau guckt ein bisschen feuerwerk streams
ja leute machts gut wir sehen uns morgen er kann uns stefan stream auch gibt es
die noch ich fand die früher schon übelst unlustig und dann waren sie auf
einmal weg und ich habe sie ehrlich gesagt auch nicht vermisst also leute
wir sehen uns machts gut bis denn zu